je vous le dis tu peux prendre mon blog
je venais au tour d'installation
[Applaudissements]
c'est les boîtes et où je dois à ma
droite a mis en garde mais tombé sur mon
jeu pour à ses débuts se passer bravo et
bravo à mathieu tu lui a sauvé la tête
alors à croquer ce combat on va revoir
les images le café de jeffrey calimero
mais thébaux avocats devraient assurer
vous inquiétez pas jean-michel monchy
russie vous aurez les risques si on va
revoir les images de francs capitaux
sont de grands présidents de ces huit
heures place au dessus de la personne
non non au dessus de nous mais à part ça
vous bah oui franc que c'est mon patron
me dire que tous les matins ils m'ont
gueule ouais voilà c'est vrai si mes
recettes du fidjien et mongols combat
scully modique je vous mets trop de
chocolat
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît reste à les bouchons
diam prenez vos places talent et vous
aider je dis bien au ballon et on
retiendra pas 4h30 comme ça je sais que
même il était cardinal roy patron du
respect là au wimax est du reste m joue
sans pales ce soir on se casse mais elle
va revoir les séquences avec avec trois
quarts étaient bonnes regardez c'est
l'élégance c'est l'élégance à la
française francs capitaux il est
toujours très élégant d'autres
présidents et j'ai décidé voilà de bien
surprendre les frais de pressing à ma
charge et il était revenue aujourd'hui
dans le studio pour que je le mets
redonne son costume il est là il en loge
il est bien voilà mon chéri merci
m'occuper de mon frère c'est adorable
merci gérer parce que c'est alors qu'il
voulait pas il est tout propre il est
tout propre et toi mon chéri franck à
pied tout je voulais dire franck toi tu
as eu de cet été était bien tu es bien
lotis il ya du président en ce moment
les émissions sont tellement drôle
c'est vrai ah oui non mais j'adore ce c
comptant des émissions mais je suis très
content des émissions alors je voudrais
dire quelque chose parce que franck mon
chéri tu as vu ce qui arrive aux
chroniqueurs total de la crème
ouais ils ont des chocolats
vous
[Applaudissements]
rock
je reprends le costume est bien sûr et
bien entendu mon chéri j'enlèverai
d'auto costumes et et je vous le dis ça
mais ce costume je vous le dis je vais
l'amener au pressing et le pressing
enlèvera tout le chocolat
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
dernis vrai qu'on a posé 17 fois
tu fais et franck est le meilleur patron
tête molle cette année
[Applaudissements]